[Music]
you've criticized the art project that
is Sophia the robot and what that
project essentially does is uses our
natural inclination to anthropomorphize
things that look like human and given
more do you think that could be used by
AI systems like in the movie her
so do you think that body is needed to
create a feeling of intelligence
well if Sophia was just an art piece I
would have no problem with it but it's
presented as something else let me add
that comics real quick if creators of
Sofia could change something about their
marketing or behavior in general what
would it be what what's just about
everything I mean don't you think here's
a tough question I mean so I agree with
you so Sofia is not in the general
public feels that Sofia can do way more
than she actually can that's right and
the people will create a Sofia are not
honestly publicly communicating trying
to teach the public right but here's a
tough question don't you think this the
same thing is scientists in industry and
research are taking advantage of the
same as misunderstanding in the public
when they create AI companies or
published stuff some companies yes I
mean there is no sense of there's no
desire to delude there's no desire to
kind of over claim what something is
done but you have your paper on AI that
you know has this result on image net
you know it's pretty clear I mean it's
not not even interesting anymore but you
know I don't think there is that I mean
the reviewers are generally not very
forgiving of of you know unsupported
claims of this type and but there are
certainly quite a few startups that have
had a huge amount of hype around this
that I find extremely damaging and I've
been calling it out when I've seen it so
yeah but to go back to your original
question like the necessity of
embodiment I think I don't think
embodiment is necessary I think
grounding is necessary so I don't think
we're gonna get machines that I really
understand language without some level
of grounding in the world world and it's
not clear to me that language is a high
enough bandwidth medium to communicate
how the real world works I think they
start to ground what grounding means so
running me is that
so there is this classic problem of
common sense reasoning you know the the
Winograd Winograd schema right and so I
tell you the the trophy doesn't fit in
the suitcase because this tool is too
big but the trophy doesn't fit in the
suitcase because it's too small and the
it in the first case refers to the
trophy in the second case of the
suitcase and the reason you can figure
this out is because you know what the
trophy in a suitcase are you know one is
supposed to fit in the other one and you
know the notion of size and the big
object doesn't fit in a small object and
this is a TARDIS you know it things like
that right so you have this got this
knowledge of how the world works of
geometry and things like that I don't
believe you can learn everything about
the world by just being told in language
how the world works I think you need
some low-level perception of the world
you know be a visual touch you know
whatever but some higher bandwidth
perception of the world so by reading
all the world's text you still may not
have enough information that's right
there's a lot of things that just will
never appear in text and that you can't
really infer so I think common sense
will emerge from you know certainly a
lot of language interaction but also
with watching videos or perhaps even
interacting in building virtual
environments and possibly you know robot
interacting in the real world but I
don't actually believe necessarily that
this last one is absolutely necessary
but I think there's a need for some
grounding but the final product doesn't
necessarily need to be embodied you know
who say no it just needs to have an
awareness a grounding right but it needs
to know how the world works to have you
know to not be frustrated first waiting
to talk to and you talked about emotions
being important that's that's a whole
nother topic well so you know I talked
about this the the basal ganglia ganglia
as the you know this thing that could
you know calculates your level of miss
constant contentment and then there is
this other module that sort of tries to
do a prediction of whether you're going
to be content or not that's the source
of some emotion so here for example is
an anticipation of bad things that can
happen to you
right
you have this inkling that there is some
chance that something really bad is
gonna happen to you and that creates
here when you know for sure that
something bad is gonna happen to you you
cannot give up right that's not right
anymore it's uncertainty it creates fear
so so the punchline is yes we're not
going to have a ton of intelligence
without emotions whatever the heck
emotions are so you mentioned very
practical things of fear but there's a
lot of other mess around but there are
kind of the results of you know drives
yeah there's deeper biological stuff
going on and I've talked a few folks on
this there's a fascinating stuff that
ultimately connects to our joy to our
brain
you